This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Imagine you had a dispute with a neighbor. It could be something trivial. Maybe he's playing music too loudly late at night and your kids can't get to sleep. The way we usually resolve these problems in daily life is to knock on our neighbor's door, explain the problem, and try to find an amicable solution. If all goes well, you discover that you have similar tastes in music. You swap playlists while getting him to keep the volume down at night. Maybe you take over soup when he's unwell and he helps you on a cold morning
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。想象一下你和邻居发生了争执。这可能是一件琐事。也许他深夜音乐放得太大声，导致你的孩子无法入睡。在日常生活中，我们通常解决这些问题的方法是敲开邻居的门，解释问题，并尝试找到一个友好的解决方案。如果一切顺利，你会发现你们在音乐品味上很相似。你们交换播放列表，同时让他晚上调低音量。也许在他身体不适时，你会送去汤，而在寒冷的早晨，他会帮你
when your car needs a jump. Now imagine that this dispute takes place on a platform like X, formerly Twitter. Instead of talking to your neighbor, you throw open your window and tell all the people on your side of the street that your neighbor is a jerk. Upset and offended, he throws open his window, which opens onto a different set of neighbors and tells those people that you're crazy. Soon, you're crazy. Soon, you're yelling at each other, but really talking to completely different sets of people. Every escalation is met with reprisal.
当你的车需要搭电时。现在想象一下，这场争执发生在像X（前身为Twitter）这样的平台上。你没有去和邻居交谈，而是推开窗户，告诉街对面所有的人你的邻居是个混蛋。他感到不安和被冒犯，于是推开窗户，对着另一群邻居说你是个疯子。很快，你们就开始互相叫喊，但实际上是在和完全不同的人群对话。每一次升级都会招致报复。
Each of you is certain the other must be dimwitted, malevolent, or unhinged. On social media, especially when it comes to political disagreements, this is often what passes for discourse. Platforms like Twitter have called these shouting matches engagement, but common sense suggests they are really a prescription for disengagement. Today, in the second installment of our series, Us 2.0, we explore why we are often unable to get through to our political opponents and how we can learn to do so. Breaking through the echo chamber, this week on Hidden Brain. There's a saying that's attributed to the Dalai Lama.
你们每个人都确信对方一定是愚蠢、心怀恶意或精神失常的。在社交媒体上，尤其是在涉及政治分歧时，这通常被视为一种交流。像Twitter这样的平台将这些争吵称为“互动”，但常识表明，它们实际上是“不互动”的处方。今天，在我们系列节目《我们2.0》的第二部分中，我们将探讨为什么我们常常无法与政治对手沟通，以及我们如何学会这样做。本周的《Hidden Brain》将带你打破回声室。有一句归功于达赖喇嘛的名言。
In the practice of tolerance, one's enemy is the best teacher. It's a nice idea, but in reality, when people don't share our values, it's hard for us to tolerate theirs. We tell ourselves they must be close-minded, illogical, immoral. They are different from us on a fundamental level. We belong to one group. They belong to another.
在宽容的修行中，敌人是最好的老师。这是一个很好的想法，但实际上，当人们与我们的价值观不一致时，我们很难宽容他们的价值观。我们告诉自己，他们一定是思想封闭、不合逻辑、不道德的。他们在根本层面上与我们不同。我们属于一个群体，他们属于另一个群体。
At Stanford University, Rob Willer studies how most of us go about persuading our opponents and why our favorite technique is strikingly ineffective. Rob Willer, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here. Rob, you were the prototypical angry young man in your college days. I want you to tell me about a conflict you once had with your roommate Russ. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I actually have a couple of stories along these lines.
在斯坦福大学，罗伯·威勒研究我们大多数人是如何试图说服对手的，以及为什么我们最喜欢的方法却出奇地无效。罗伯·威勒，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。罗伯，你在大学时代是一个典型的愤怒青年。我想请你讲讲你曾经和室友拉斯发生的一次冲突。是的，是的。我的意思是，我确实有几个这方面的故事。
So in this time of my life, maybe from like 19 to 21, the central axis of conflict for me was around sleep. And I remember one morning, my friend Russ was waking up, he had a job at a copy center, and he was just doing what somebody does in the morning, talking to another one of our roommates and hanging out, drinking coffee, getting the day going. It's like 9.30 in the morning or something, but I've been late working at a restaurant, second shift, and I'm sleeping in.
在我人生的那个阶段，大概是19到21岁，我冲突的核心轴是关于睡眠。我记得有一天早上，我的朋友拉斯起床了，他在一家复印中心工作，他只是在做早上人们会做的事，和我们的另一个室友聊天、闲逛、喝咖啡，开始新的一天。当时大概是早上9点半左右，但我因为在餐馆上晚班，是第二班，所以我还在睡懒觉。
I can't sleep, right? Because of this noise coming from the living room at this unacceptable time of the morning. And I just came rushing out of my room, like immediately inflamed, you know, dropping epithets and, you know, cursing. And I remember like Russ was so caught off guard. He's like the sweetest guy in my roommate. And he just was like,
我睡不着，对吧？因为在这个早晨不可接受的时间里，客厅里传来了噪音。我立刻冲出房间，火冒三丈，你知道，满口脏话，咒骂着。我记得拉斯当时非常吃惊。他是我室友里最贴心的人。他只是说，
you. And I remember I got so mad that I took this whiteboard that we would use to write messages to each other and I like slammed it against a wall. Wow. This is just completely out of control. Sometime later, Rob had another run in with a different roommate. This one changed the course of his life.
你。我记得我当时非常生气，以至于我拿起我们用来互相留言的白板，狠狠地砸在墙上。哇。这简直完全失控了。后来，罗伯和另一个室友又发生了一次冲突。这一次改变了他的人生轨迹。
I was a junior in college. I was sharing a house with my friend Jim, my roommate, and he was up in the morning making eggs for breakfast as one does. It's like 10 in the morning or something. It's not even that early, but I was a night owl, I would work late, hang out with people late at night, sleep in in the morning, and he's making a lot of noise, right? With the frying pan and so on. My bedroom is just off the kitchen. My first approach to this, to conflict resolution here, or to resolving the situation, was to
我上大学三年级时，和我的朋友吉姆合租一栋房子，他是我的室友。那天早上他起床做早餐，就像人们常做的那样。大概是早上10点左右。甚至不算太早，但我是一个夜猫子，我工作到很晚，晚上和朋友闲逛，早上睡懒觉，而他在制造很大的噪音，对吧？用平底锅什么的。我的卧室就在厨房旁边。我解决冲突或解决这种情况的第一个方法是
throw a shoe against the door, which I think is considered an international signal of please be quieter, you know. And with your inside your own bedroom and you throw a shoe at your own bedroom door to tell him to pipe down. Yeah, that's right. So that didn't work because it couldn't be decoded as I intended it. So then I came out of the bedroom, just immediately angry, already turned all the way up to 11 and I'm like, you need to not make all this noise
往门上扔一只鞋，我认为这被视为一种国际通用的“请安静一点”的信号，你知道。当你待在自己的卧室里，往自己的卧室门上扔一只鞋来告诉他安静点。是的，没错。但这没用，因为它无法被解读为我预期的意思。于是我走出卧室，立刻就生气了，情绪直接飙升到11级，我说，你需要在这么早的早上
so early in the morning, probably cursing and whatnot. And he's totally taken it back and himself upset about this. And now we're in this heated argument and I slammed the door behind me, can't go back to sleep because I'm all worked up now. And the whole exercise is self-defeating at every level. Rob thought back to this altercation with Jim
不要制造这么多噪音，可能还伴随着咒骂之类的。他完全被吓到了，自己也很生气。现在我们陷入了激烈的争吵，我摔门而出，因为我现在情绪激动，无法再回去睡觉了。整个过程在各个层面上都是自取灭亡。罗伯回想起这次与吉姆的争执
when one of his social science professors gave him an interesting assignment. It was to mark a turning point in his life. Yeah, yeah, so it was its great assignment. And my professor, Professor Michael Lavalia at University of Iowa, he had us first write an essay, a short essay about a recent conflict we'd been in and to just go off on the person we were in a conflict with,
当时他的一位社会科学教授给了他一个有趣的作业。这是一个标志他人生转折点的作业。是的，是的，这是一个很棒的作业。我的教授，爱荷华大学的迈克尔·拉瓦利亚教授，他让我们先写一篇短文，关于我们最近经历的一次冲突，并让我们尽情地发泄对冲突对象的不满，
you know, just render our perspective as vividly as possible. So I did that, you know, defending all of my choices in this situation as one does. And then the catch was, after we turned this in, he said, okay, the second short essay assignment is for you to now write the exact same essay about the same conflict. However, you're supposed to write it from the perspective of the person who you were in the conflict with. And the best version of this, you would actually simulate as accurately as you can what they would have written if they had gotten this assignment.
你知道，尽可能生动地呈现我们的观点。所以我照做了，你知道，像往常一样为我在这种情况下的所有选择辩护。然后重点来了，在我们交了作业后，他说，好吧，第二个短文作业是让你现在写一篇关于同一冲突的完全相同的文章。然而，你需要从你发生冲突的那个人的角度来写。最好的版本是，你尽可能准确地模拟如果他们接到这个作业会写些什么。
So you're totally in their first person perspective. And so I did that. And for me, honestly, it was a pretty revelatory experience. So I sit down to write this essay, and now I'm writing an essay from my roommate's perspective, and it's coming out, of course, completely differently. So now I'm talking about how I woke up one morning. I was hungry for breakfast. And so I went and started to mix eggs on my stove and halfway through making them,
所以你完全处于他们的第一人称视角。我照做了。老实说，对我来说，这是一次相当具有启示性的经历。我坐下来写这篇文章，现在我从室友的角度写，当然，写出来的内容完全不同。所以现在我在谈论我早上醒来，想吃早餐。于是我去炉子上开始搅拌鸡蛋，在做了一半的时候，
there's a loud noise on the wall from apparently inside my roommate Rob's bedroom. I don't know what this is. I ignore it and continue. And I'm about done making my tasty, healthy breakfast when all of a sudden this mad person, you know, comes storming out of Rob's bedroom, you know, ranting at me about how I'm being too loud
墙上突然传来一声巨响，显然是从我室友罗伯的卧室里传来的。我不知道这是什么。我忽略它并继续。我快要做完美味健康的早餐时，突然这个疯子，你知道，从罗伯的卧室里冲出来，你知道，对我咆哮，说我太吵了，
when I'm really just making eggs and maybe whistling or something. And I start engaging back. You know, I'm next thing I know, I'm in an argument out of nowhere with little to no provocation on my end. And so that's the essay I wrote, the second essay, the one from my roommate Jim's perspective. And this might seem silly for people who take the perspective
而我其实只是在做鸡蛋，可能还在吹口哨什么的。我开始反击。你知道，接下来我知道的是，我莫名其妙地陷入了一场争吵，而我这边几乎没有任何挑衅。所以这就是我写的文章，第二篇，从我室友吉姆的角度写的。对于那些更容易站在他人角度思考，或者在生活中经历过的人来说，这似乎很傻，
of other people more readily or have in their lives. But for me, this was like a pretty revelatory experience because I, for perhaps the very first time in my entire life, had really, really deeply and authentically taken the perspective of somebody else when it was hard. When I was sure I was right, when I had a bunch of emotion and righteousness invested in my side, and I had gotten over that for the purposes of getting an A on this assignment in college and embrace the other person's perspective. And then I saw that they were right, you know, and I was wrong, or at least it was at least
但对我来说，这是一次相当具有启示性的经历，因为我可能是我一生中第一次真正、深刻且真实地站在别人的角度思考，尤其是在困难的时候。当我确信自己是对的，当我投入了大量的情感和正义感在自己这一边时，为了在大学里拿到A，我克服了这些，拥抱了对方的视角。然后我看到他们是对的，你知道，而我是错的，或者至少是
80, 20 that they were right. And that was a first, you know, I was a kind of angry young man type around that time, as you can guess from the story. And that was a needed and revelatory lesson for me. You know, there's an emotional power to this exercise, which, you know, I'm not sure people might anticipate experiencing, but when you do this, it's not just that you start to see things from another person's point of view, but the story itself feels like an entirely different story.
80%对20%他们是对的。那是一个第一次，你知道，从故事里你可以猜到，我当时是一个有点愤怒的年轻人。那对我来说是一个必要且具有启示性的教训。你知道，这个练习有一种情感力量，你知道，我不确定人们是否预料到会经历这种力量，但当你这样做时，不仅仅是你开始从另一个人的角度看问题，而且故事本身感觉就像一个完全不同的故事。
That's exactly right. Yeah, it's not just that you're getting out of your head into somebody else's, but you're accessing entirely different information, maybe. So as I'm simulating what it must be like to make breakfast, I'm in a completely different world. Now I'm, you know, guessing at the experience that Jim's having, but I'm now seeing and hearing and thinking things that I couldn't have known, you know, when I was locked in my own perspective. When someone believes the world revolves around them, we think they are selfish, unkind or oblivious. Yet all of us are born with a subjective view of the world revolves around them, we think they are selfish, unkind or oblivious. Yet all of us are born with a subjective view of the world. It's only natural to see things from our own perspective.
完全正确。是的，这不仅仅是你跳出自己的思维进入别人的思维，你可能还在获取完全不同的信息。所以当我模拟做早餐是什么感觉时，我处于一个完全不同的世界。现在我，你知道，在猜测吉姆的经历，但我现在看到、听到和思考的事情，是我在被锁在自己的视角时无法知道的。当一个人认为世界围绕着他们转时，我们认为他们自私、不友善或健忘。然而，我们所有人天生都有一种主观的世界观。从我们自己的角度看问题是很自然的。
When we come back, the effects this has on our political conversations and how understanding what happens inside our own minds is the first step to changing someone else's mind. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Think back to the last disagreement you had with someone. Maybe it was a fight with your partner or a co-worker over the thermostat setting or a more serious argument with a relative over politics. Did the disagreement go well, or did it end with both sides feeling frustrated and misunderstood? Chances are, it's the latter.
当我们回来时，我们将探讨这对我们的政治对话有什么影响，以及了解我们自己内心发生的事情是如何改变他人想法的第一步。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回想一下你最近与某人的分歧。也许是你和伴侣或同事关于恒温器设置的争吵，或者是与亲戚关于政治的更严重的争论。分歧解决得好吗，还是以双方都感到沮丧和被误解而告终？很有可能是后者。
Rob Willer used to have many experiences like this. When he was a kid, his family moved from Kansas to South Carolina. It was something of a culture shock, and Rob was pretty sure that everyone around him had the world completely wrong. I had grown up in Lawrence, Kansas, and my parents were super progressive, secular folks, and I was living in this very progressive college town in Kansas, and then got splashed down in South Carolina in 1988, in Columbia, South Carolina. It was a real shock to be suddenly, you know, in the middle school that had only been integrated
罗伯·威勒过去常有这样的经历。他小时候，全家从堪萨斯州搬到了南卡罗来纳州。这是一种文化冲击，罗伯非常确信他周围的所有人都完全搞错了世界。我在堪萨斯州的劳伦斯长大，我的父母是非常进步、世俗的人，我住在堪萨斯州这个非常进步的大学城，然后在1988年被“空投”到了南卡罗来纳州的哥伦比亚市。突然置身于一所仅仅在20年前才实现种族融合的中学，
less than 20 years earlier, and in a place where the, you know, the scars of the civil war, they're right on the surface. They're not far away. Did you find yourself getting into arguments and conversations with people around you? Yeah, for sure, for sure, including with history teachers, with peers. I mean, to me, it was totally shocking to be taught a history of the civil war that was just strikingly at odds with the one I was raised to understand.
而且在一个内战的伤痕依然清晰可见的地方，这真是一种冲击。它们并不遥远。你发现自己和周围的人发生争论和对话了吗？是的，当然，当然，包括和历史老师、同龄人。我的意思是，对我来说，被教导一种与我从小被灌输的完全不同的内战历史，真是太令人震惊了。
In high school, you had a friend named Andy, and you would often get into arguments with him about the Confederate flag. How did these go? What did you try and do in these discussions with Andy? Yeah. So, the meaning of the Confederate flag was a topic of some debate in Columbia, South Carolina at this time, because the Confederate flag was flying above our state capital in Columbia. People would debate a lot, what did this mean?
在高中时，你有一个叫安迪的朋友，你经常和他争论关于邦联旗的问题。这些争论是怎么进行的？你在这些与安迪的讨论中尝试做了什么？是的。所以，邦联旗的含义在当时的南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚市是一个争论的话题，因为邦联旗在哥伦比亚的州议会大厦上空飘扬。人们经常争论，这意味着什么？
Was this okay? And I was inclined to debate just about anyone on this topic and wound up debating with my friend Andy, who we were actually on the debate team together. And I would advocate for how that flag needed to come down, that regardless of what people might associate with it, that it was a symbol of racism, of racial domination, and if it ever had a time, that time was certainly gone. And Andy would say the opposite.
这可以吗？我倾向于在这个话题上与任何人辩论，最终和我的朋友安迪辩论，我们实际上在同一个辩论队。我会主张那面旗帜需要降下来，无论人们可能将它与什么联系起来，它都是种族主义、种族统治的象征，如果它曾经有过存在的时代，那个时代肯定已经过去了。而安迪会说相反的话。
He'd say, that's not what it means to me, and that's not what it means to the people I know and people in my family. It's a symbol of our history. And we lost the Civil War, and it's this kind of sad thing deep in our history, and this is a way for us to maintain some pride around that. And then I would come back and say,
他说，那对我来说不是那个意思，对我也认识的人和我家人来说也不是那个意思。它是我们历史的象征。我们输掉了内战，这是我们历史深处的一种悲伤的事情，这是我们保持某种自豪感的一种方式。然后我会反驳说，
well, but the flag went up there during racial integration battles in the 1960s. It didn't go up in the 19th century. And we would go back and forth in this way. And the thing is that I never convinced Andy even a little bit or probably anyone else I ever debated on this subject. I mean, it's almost like you were imagining that this was an actual debate where there was a judge, a neutral judge, who would listen to both arguments and then decide which person had the better argument.
嗯，但那面旗帜是在20世纪60年代种族融合斗争期间升上去的。它不是在19世纪升上去的。我们就这样来回争论。问题是，我从来没有说服过安迪哪怕一点点，或者可能是我在这个话题上辩论过的任何人。我的意思是，这简直就像你想象这是一场真正的辩论，有一个法官，一个中立的法官，会听取双方的论点，然后决定哪个人有更好的论点。
Exactly. A godlike figure that simply wasn't there. And I got this idea in part because I was on the logic of your argument, and to destroy the other person's argument. Because in the culture and structure of high school debate, that was pretty much rewarded. The other thing that I think is worth pointing out is that in a debate, you could get points for how passionate you are. So in other words, the more fervently you argue your point of view, that could tell a neutral judge, this person really cares about the argument,
完全正确。一个根本不存在的神一般的形象。我产生这个想法部分是因为我当时在辩论队的逻辑中，要摧毁对方的论点。因为在高中辩论的文化和结构中，这在很大程度上是受到奖励的。我认为还有一点值得指出的是，在辩论中，你可以因为你的激情而得分。换句话说，你越热烈地争论你的观点，这就能告诉中立的法官，这个人真的很关心这个论点，
put in a lot of time and heart into the argument. I'm gonna give a few more points for the passion that this person is demonstrating. Of course, this passion doesn't go very far when it comes to convincing our opponents as opposed to some neutral judge. Yeah, and in a way, I think that while I really, really value the experience I had in debate of having to think really, really hard about holes in my opponent's argument and then passionately and as logically as I could expose those holes and make a stronger argument and response,
在论点中投入了大量的时间和心血。我会给这个表现出激情的人多加几分。当然，当涉及到说服我们的对手而不是某个中立的法官时，这种激情并没有多大作用。是的，在某种程度上，我认为虽然我非常、非常重视在辩论中必须非常、非常努力地思考对手论点中的漏洞，然后充满激情且尽可能合乎逻辑地揭露这些漏洞，并做出更有力的反驳，
I also was just like weekend after weekend, year after year, getting my reps in on my perspective, you know, and how to prosecute it passionately and intensely. And I wasn't getting really any reps in on understanding someone else's perspective. So I was, you know, coming out of high school, I was still on the ground floor on that journey. When you get to Cornell University and you're in graduate school, you decide to try and
但我也是周末复周末，年复一年地在我的观点上进行练习，你知道，以及如何充满激情和强烈地去执行它。而我并没有在理解别人的观点上进行任何练习。所以，你知道，我高中毕业时，在那段旅程中仍然处于起步阶段。当你进入康奈尔大学读研究生时，你决定尝试
organize students into a union, graduate students into a union, and you start to recruit people to the cause. I'm wondering if you can tell me how you went about doing this and whether you learned something different than your exploits as a high school debater. Yes, this was a fascinating experience at a number of levels. So I was working as a union organizer trying to organize graduate students on campus into a union for teaching assistants and research assistants and my position involved striking up conversations with graduate students and trying to get them involved and interested in the union. And sometimes I'd be going to the English department, sometimes I'd be
组织学生成立工会，研究生工会，你开始招募人们加入这项事业。我想知道你能不能告诉我你是怎么做的，以及你是否学到了与你高中辩论时不同的东西。是的，这在多个层面上都是一次迷人的经历。当时我是一名工会组织者，试图在校园里组织研究生加入助教和研究助理的工会，我的工作涉及与研究生展开对话，并试图让他们参与并对工会感兴趣。有时我会去英语系，有时我会
going to the math department, so I remember on one occasion I go to the English department and I strike up a conversation with a woman who was a PhD student in English and she was a Marxist theorist. Rob quickly assumed that he would have no trouble persuading the young woman to join the union. She was a Marxist, and Karl Marx was surely the patron saint of the working class. But to his surprise, the conversation wasn't going well. I'm explaining what we're trying to do, the benefits that it could offer graduate students, in my view, and the evidence for unionization, and I'm just making my case. But I can tell it's not connecting.
去数学系，所以我记得有一次我去了英语系，和一个英语专业的博士生交谈，她是一位马克思主义理论家。罗伯很快认为他劝说这位年轻女性加入工会不会有任何困难。她是马克思主义者，而卡尔·马克思无疑是工人阶级的守护神。但令他惊讶的是，对话进行得并不顺利。我解释我们试图做什么，在我看来它能为研究生提供的福利，以及工会化的证据，我只是在陈述我的理由。但我能感觉到它没有产生共鸣。
She seemed sort of distant, maybe about halfway through this kind of boilerplate spiel. And I was like, what do you think? You know, what do you think about all this? And she was like, well, I'm trying to think of this from a Marxist perspective. I'm kind of curious how Marx would think about this. And I was like, okay, that was not the conversation I thought I'd be in, but I can do this. Okay, so there's different Marxist views on union organizing. One is that it is just a band-aid. You slap onto the status quo that only makes things look superficially better, but pushes
她看起来有点疏远，可能在这一套标准说辞进行到一半时。我说，你觉得怎么样？你知道，你对这一切有什么看法？她说，嗯，我正在尝试从马克思主义的角度思考这个问题。我很好奇马克思会怎么想。我说，好吧，那不是我以为会进行的对话，但我可以做到。好吧，关于工会组织有不同的马克思主义观点。一种观点是，这只是一个创可贴。你贴在现状上，只会让事情表面上看起来好一点，但推迟了
off the inevitable communist revolution that's going to bring utopian workers collective to power. There's another version of Marxian thinking that says, no, this is consistent with performing capitalism and addressing the harms of unregulated market economies and unions are actually really helpful, you know, and consistent with Marxist critiques of the status quo. And I was like, I'm a little more of the latter persuasion, but I can understand either perspective,
不可避免的共产主义革命，那将把乌托邦式的工人集体带入权力中心。还有另一种马克思主义思想，认为不，这与改良资本主义和解决不受监管的市场经济的危害是一致的，工会实际上非常有帮助，你知道，并且与马克思主义对现状的批判是一致的。我说，我更倾向于后者，但我可以理解任何一种观点，
what do you think? And now we're talking about whether one should take a more extreme or more moderate version of a Marxist perspective on the union. And we get there, she winds up being a supporter of the union, but for me, it was one of these initial experiences of figuring it out, like you're gonna have to get into potentially a very different headspace.
你觉得呢？现在我们正在讨论一个人是否应该采取更极端或更温和的马克思主义观点来看待工会。我们达成了共识，她最终成为了工会的支持者，但对我来说，这是我最初弄清楚的经历之一，就像你必须进入一个可能非常不同的思维空间。
In each conversation, that might be an very different headspace, you know, in each conversation that might be an entirely different headspace in order to have productive conversations. Rob managed to win over the Marxist, but it was an early signal to him that ultimately she didn't join the Union for his reasons. She joined the Union for her reasons. Some time later, Rob met another graduate student, this time in the math department. We were losing math. You know, like we were doing badly in math and it was becoming a pretty anti-union department. And I was even hesitant to go back there just because I'd had bad
在每一次对话中，那可能是一个非常不同的思维空间，你知道，在每一次对话中，那可能是一个完全不同的思维空间，以便进行富有成效的对话。罗伯成功说服了那位马克思主义者，但这对他来说是一个早期的信号，最终她加入工会并不是因为他的理由。她加入工会是因为她自己的理由。后来，罗伯遇到了另一位研究生，这次是在数学系。我们正在失去数学系。你知道，就像我们在数学系表现得很糟糕，它变成了一个相当反工会的部门。我甚至犹豫要不要回去，只是因为我有过糟糕的
experiences and this really nice advanced graduate student was like, hey you want to go for a walk and we can talk about this and I was like yes I would love to get out of this space and into another one that'd be great because it was sort of intimidating because I had this sense that people maybe didn't want me there. So we go for a walk and we just very, very carefully go through all of the different reasons for and against unionization, the main ones. And one thing he's emphasizing is uncertainty
经历，而这位非常好的高年级研究生说，嘿，你想去散散步，我们可以谈谈这个吗？我说，是的，我很乐意离开这个空间，进入另一个空间，那太好了，因为它有点令人生畏，因为我有一种感觉，人们可能不希望我在那里。所以我们去散步，我们非常、非常仔细地梳理了所有支持和反对工会化的不同理由，主要的那些。他强调的一件事是不确定性，
and how whenever he's seen uncertainty left over that he kind of has a conservative response of not changing things too much because things aren't going that badly for him. And so, you know, where he's not sure what would happen from unionization, that's kind of points on the board for the status quo. But when he initially said that the status quo might be better, didn't you feel inclined to argue with him to sort of say, no, no, no, of course not.
以及每当他看到剩下的不确定性时，他就会有一种保守的反应，即不要改变太多事情，因为对他来说事情并没有那么糟糕。所以，你知道，在他不确定工会化会带来什么结果的地方，这在某种程度上是现状的加分项。但当他最初说现状可能更好时，你难道没有感到想要反驳他，说，不，不，不，当然不是。
You're wrong. Oh, definitely. So I would come back and say yes, but there's pretty consistent empirical evidence that you're going to get gains in wages and benefits here. Look at campuses X, Y, and Z, and he would come back like, okay, but we also got a 3% raise last year. We just got health insurance a couple years ago,
你错了。哦，当然。所以我反驳说，是的，但有相当一致的实证证据表明，你在这里会获得工资和福利的增长。看看X、Y和Z校园，他会反驳说，好吧，但我们去年也加薪了3%。我们几年前才刚有了健康保险，
so I kind of feel like in this case, the status quo is giving me what I need, and I don't know where all this extra money is gonna come from on campus. And at the end of the conversation, we basically agreed that we did disagree, but that we disagreed less than when we started, that he was a little more positive towards unionization and that I was more respectful and understanding of why somebody wouldn't
所以我感觉在这种情况下，现状给了我所需要的，我不知道校园里所有这些额外的钱会从哪里来。在对话结束时，我们基本上同意我们确实有分歧，但我们比开始时分歧小了，他对比工会化稍微积极了一些，而我对比为什么有人会不支持它更加尊重和理解，
support it, in particular based on the sort of risk calculation. We came to see each other's perspectives and a key part of it was that I changed my mind a little bit in the conversation. As a union organizer, Rob learned his goal wasn't to win a debate. It was to actually change someone's behavior. It was definitely different from the kind of persuasion that I had been taught to embrace through high school debate, but it was way more effective. It was way more interested in the other person and it was just really inclusive.
特别是基于那种风险计算。我们开始看到彼此的观点，关键部分是我在对话中稍微改变了我的想法。作为一名工会组织者，罗伯学到他的目标不是赢得辩论。而是真正改变某人的行为。这绝对不同于我通过高中辩论被教导要拥抱的那种说服方式，但它更有效。它更关注对方，而且真的非常包容。
You can't afford when you're organizing a union to write somebody off or write off their perspective or not try to have a productive conversation. You're trying to get everybody on board. And so there's a pragmatism to organize labor circles that I hadn't really encountered in my political background, which was more about debating for that mythical god-like neutral third party that just wasn't there. One of the things that I'm observing from what you just said is that when we have debates with people and we argue with people, we're not actually just trying to have them come over to our side, to our point of view.
当你组织工会时，你负担不起写掉某人或写掉他们的观点，或者不尝试进行富有成效的对话。你试图让每个人都加入。因此，劳工组织圈子里有一种实用主义，我在我的政治背景中并没有真正遇到过，那更多是关于为那个根本不存在的神话般的、中立的第三方而辩论。我从你刚才说的话中观察到的一件事是，当我们与人辩论和争论时，我们实际上并不只是试图让他们来到我们这边，来到我们的观点。
We want them to come over to our point of view for our reasons. And one of the things I'm picking up from your conversations with various people is that as you were talking to people, you were almost indifferent. If someone says, I'm going to weigh Marxist theory and figure out a path to join the union, great. If someone in the math department says, I'm going to do a cost-benefit analysis and that's how I'm going to join the union, you're fine with that as well. So in some ways, you're less interested in the motivations and the reasons that people
我们希望他们因为我们的理由而来到我们的观点。我从你与各种人的对话中捕捉到的一件事是，当你和人们交谈时，你几乎是漠不关心的。如果有人说，我要权衡马克思主义理论并找出加入工会的途径，太好了。如果数学系的人说，我要做一个成本效益分析，这就是我加入工会的方式，你也对此没问题。所以从某种程度上说，你对人们的动机和理由不那么感兴趣。
have. And as you said, much more pragmatic about the end goal. Yeah, that's exactly right. I wasn't going to convince the English graduate student to not embrace critical Marxist theory. I wasn't going to convince the math graduate student to be less analytical. Those were givens.
正如你所说，对最终目标更加务实。是的，完全正确。我不会说服那位英语研究生不去拥抱批判性的马克思主义理论。我不会说服那位数学研究生变得不那么分析。这些都是既定的。
I had maybe 30 minutes to go from where they're at to them seeing my perspective on this issue, or at least considering agreeing with me. And that meant meeting them where they were and paying them that respect. Rob realized his first job in trying to persuade someone was not to marshal all the arguments at his disposal. It was to find some way to make a connection with the other person. I think that for me, these conversations would go better if I had something I could tap into from my own background, my own personal experience that would allow me to sort of build that bridge to their perspective.
我可能有30分钟的时间，从他们所处的位置让他们看到我对此事的看法，或者至少考虑同意我。这意味着在他们所在的地方与他们会面，并给予他们尊重。罗伯意识到他试图说服某人的第一项工作不是调动他所能支配的所有论点。而是找到某种方式与对方建立联系。我认为对我来说，如果我能从自己的背景、自己的个人经历中挖掘出一些东西，让我能够建立起通往他们视角的桥梁，这些对话会进行得更好。
The way I often think about this is that empathy or perspective taking, it's like a bridge you build between people and the blocks that you're using to build it are pieces of your own experience. You can say, oh, I know about Marxist theory too. Let's talk about this. Or, oh, I've actually engaged in a cost-benefit analysis on this too. Let me know what you think of what I did. Here's what I came up with. And when you've got those blocks, it goes a lot easier once you figure out where you need to be building towards. That wasn't the hardest part though.
我经常这样想，同理心或视角转换，就像你在人与人之间建立的一座桥梁，你用来建造它的砖块是你自己经历的碎片。你可以说，哦，我也了解马克思主义理论。让我们谈谈这个。或者，哦，我实际上也对此进行过成本效益分析。让我知道你对我所做的事情有什么看法。这是我想出的。当你有了这些砖块，一旦你弄清楚你需要往哪里建设，事情就容易多了。但这并不是最困难的部分。
Rob realized that when he was trying to persuade people, he needed to have conversations with them. Conversations where he wasn't doing all the talking. It really is helpful to establish some sort of basic respect, a basic emotional connection of like, I'm respecting your perspective, and I have enough intellectual humility to be also listening to you.
罗伯意识到，当他试图说服人们时，他需要与他们进行对话。那种他不是一直在说话的对话。建立某种基本的尊重，一种基本的、像“我尊重你的观点，并且我有足够的智力谦逊来倾听你”的情感联系，真的很有帮助。
And also that I'm open to persuasion in this conversation as well. Because if you signal really early in the conversation that you're not open to changing their mind, you're asking a lot for the other person to be open to it. And if there isn't a power imbalance that dictates that they have to, they're going to withhold that openness if you're not showing it as well. There are many reasons it's hard to come across as open.
而且我也在这次对话中对说服持开放态度。因为如果你在对话很早的时候就发出信号说你不愿意改变他们的想法，你要求对方对此开放是要求太高了。如果不存在强制他们必须这样做的权力失衡，如果你自己不表现出这种开放，他们就会保留这种开放。有很多原因让人很难表现得开放。
When we care passionately about something, it becomes hard to see things from other points of view. The more we care, the harder it becomes to see that our perspective is just our perspective, not the only perspective. Second, many of us unconsciously assume that others know the same facts and information that inform our views. We forget other people have been exposed to different information, sometimes radically different information. To make things even more complicated, what our opponents believe is not just about the information they've received.
当我们充满激情地关心某事时，就很难从其他角度看问题。我们越关心，就越难看到我们的视角只是我们的视角，而不是唯一的视角。其次，我们许多人无意识地假设别人知道与我们观点相同的事实和信息。我们忘记了其他人接触到了不同的信息，有时是截然不同的信息。让事情变得更复杂的是，我们的对手所相信的不仅仅是他们收到的信息。
Their beliefs are also shaped by their unconscious drives and motivations. If we don't know how they came to their positions, we might never understand why they believe what they believe. That's right. Yeah. And so if you're debating with somebody about an issue you disagree with them on where you'd like them to come over to your side, but your arguments are entirely in terms of your moral worldview, your background, your ideology, your cultural perspective,
他们的信仰也受到他们无意识的驱动和动机的影响。如果我们不知道他们是如何得出自己的立场的，我们可能永远不会理解他们为什么相信他们所相信的。没错。是的。所以如果你正在和一个你不同意的议题与某人辩论，你希望他们来到你这边，但你的论点完全是基于你的道德世界观、你的背景、你的意识形态、你的文化视角，
and you're making those kinds of arguments and they have a different background, a different ideology, a different worldview, you're essentially asking them to really be someone they're not, like to not just agree with you on the thing in question, but also to change their deeply held moral values, for example, but asking somebody to give up their moral values,
而你正在提出这些论点，而他们有不同的背景、不同的意识形态、不同的世界观，你本质上是在要求他们真正成为他们不是的人，比如不仅在相关问题上同意你，而且还要改变他们根深蒂固的道德价值观，例如，但要求某人放弃他们的道德价值观，
people are willing to fight and die for their values. People really, really are invested in not changing their minds about that. So if the argument you're presenting to them requires them to change their values, you are taking on a much bigger task than just changing somebody's mind on minimum wage law. And you could prosecute your case better if you made an argument that could fit with their values rather than challenge them.
人们愿意为他们的价值观而战甚至牺牲。人们真的、真的投入于不改变他们对此的看法。所以如果你向他们提出的论点要求他们改变价值观，你承担的任务比仅仅改变某人对最低工资法的看法要大得多。如果你能提出一个符合他们价值观而不是挑战他们的论点，你就能更好地执行你的案例。
So there's something of a dilemma here, Rob, which is when we feel really passionately about something, when we're really upset about something or we're in disagreement with someone, and that could be a romantic partner or a co-worker or even a political opponent, the angrier and more upset we get, the harder it becomes for us to see things from another person's point of view. And you're saying that's precisely the point at which we need to see things from another person's point of view if we're going to have any effectiveness. There seems to be a real dilemma here, a paradox. Yeah, I think there is. if we're going to have any effectiveness. There seems to be a real dilemma here, a paradox.
所以这里有一个困境，罗伯，那就是当我们对某事感到非常激动时，当我们对某事感到非常不安或与某人有分歧时，这可能是浪漫伴侣、同事甚至是政治对手，我们越生气、越不安，我们就越难从别人的角度看问题。而你说这正是我们需要从别人的角度看问题的时候，如果我们想有任何效果的话。这里似乎有一个真正的困境，一个悖论。是的，我想是有的。
Yeah, I think there is. And it's a very difficult thing, because it's exactly those people who are motivated to change the views of others, who then have this motivation that can get in the way. Why? Because they can become angry at the person they're talking with, they can become impatient. And these are all understandable reactions. There's nothing wrong with feeling strongly about something. It's a good thing, I think. I feel strongly about a lot of stuff.
是的，我想是有的。这是一件非常困难的事情，因为正是那些有动力去改变他人观点的人，他们才会有这种可能阻碍他们的动机。为什么？因为他们可能会对他们交谈的人感到愤怒，他们可能会变得不耐烦。这些都是可以理解的反应。对某事有强烈的感觉并没有错。我认为这是一件好事。我对很多事情都有强烈的感觉。
A lot of stuff makes me angry too. It's kind of what do you do then, and what goal are you trying to pursue? And if the goal is persuading somebody, you may need to down-regulate that emotional reaction and focus on getting into that person's head in order to construct an argument that would be persuasive to them.
很多事情也让我生气。这有点像你那时该怎么办，你试图追求什么目标？如果目标是说服某人，你可能需要下调那种情绪反应，专注于进入那个人的头脑，以便构建一个对他们有说服力的论点。
We ran a recent episode featuring the research of the psychologist and neuroscientist, Kurt Gray at the University of North Carolina. He talked about the importance of moral humility. We talk a lot about intellectual humility, the idea that we may not know everything and that we might be wrong about the things we think we know. But moral humility is about emotionally accepting that the feelings of people who think differently from us are legitimate. You talk about this idea too.
我们最近播出了一集，介绍了北卡罗来纳大学心理学家和神经科学家库尔特·格雷的研究。他谈到了道德谦逊的重要性。我们谈论了很多智力谦逊，即我们可能不知道一切，我们可能对我们认为知道的事情是错误的。但道德谦逊是关于情感上接受那些想法与我们不同的人的感受是合法的。你也谈到了这个想法。
Tell me about your notion of moral empathy. Yeah. So, one thing that we find in our research is that people whose political worldviews are rooted in their moral values, who really deeply moralize their perspective on some political issue, they are the ones that especially struggle to understand the perspective of people who disagree with them, and to understand that the most persuasive appeal would be one that might not be
告诉我你关于道德同理心的概念。是的。所以，我们在研究中发现的一件事是，那些政治世界观植根于道德价值观的人，那些真正深刻地将他们对某些政治议题的看法道德化的人，他们是特别难以理解那些与他们有分歧的人的视角的人，也难以理解最有说服力的呼吁可能不是
persuasive to them. That doesn't mean you're wrong if you have that kind of moral investment, but it does mean that it's going to be hard to connect. Can you talk about the role of our own emotions here in some ways? Partly, we're so angry and so upset and so outraged about things that it becomes very difficult for us to say, what do I have in common with these people on the other side of the barricades? Yeah. So once you have a strong connection to your political identity, it becomes very easy for
对他们有说服力的。如果你有那种道德投入，并不意味着你是错的，但这确实意味着很难建立联系。你能谈谈我们自己的情绪在这里的作用吗？在某种程度上，我们对障碍另一边的人感到如此愤怒、如此不安、如此愤慨，以至于我们很难说，我和这些在障碍另一边的人有什么共同点？是的。所以一旦你与你的政治身份建立了强烈的联系，你就很容易
you to trigger this, for you to experience this emotionally laden frustration, even contempt for the people on the other side of the political divide, people that have a rival political identity. And when you realize you're in an interaction that is connected to those identities, you now import, and they may too, all of this baggage from all the thinking you've been doing about how frustrated you are with these other folks. And so you're not just having a conversation about school zoning or whatever you think you're discussing. You're bringing all this other stuff into it too.
触发这种情绪，让你体验到这种充满情感的挫败感，甚至是对政治分歧另一边的人的蔑视，那些拥有竞争性政治身份的人。当你意识到你处于一种与这些身份相关的互动中时，你现在就导入了，他们可能也是，所有这些关于你如何对这些人感到沮丧的思考带来的包袱。所以你不仅仅是在进行关于学校分区或任何你认为你在讨论的事情的对话。你还把所有其他东西都带进去了。
You're also thinking about gay rights and you're also thinking about race in America and maybe economic inequality and immigration and what you saw last night on MSNBC or Fox News and what they probably saw. And once all that stuff is brought into the debate, things get really, really difficult to resolve in a constructive way. Connection and moral empathy are prerequisites for persuasion.
你还在思考同性恋权利，你还在思考美国的种族问题，也许还有经济不平等和移民，以及你昨晚在MSNBC或福克斯新闻上看到的，以及他们可能看到的。一旦所有这些东西被带入辩论，事情就变得非常、非常难以以建设性的方式解决。联系和道德同理心是说服的前提。
If you want to change hearts and minds, you have to understand what's in those hearts and minds to begin with. Most of us try to bypass this requirement, focusing only on what's inside our own heart and our own mind. When we come back, strategies we can all learn to become more persuasive. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. In the 13th century, the Italian mystic St. Francis of Assisi offered up a prayer. In it, he said, it was more important to understand others than to be understood by others. It was good advice 800 years ago, and it turns out to be good advice today. And not just from a spiritual point of view, it turns out to be psychologically insightful when it comes to our ability to influence others.
如果你想改变人心，你首先必须了解人心。我们大多数人试图绕过这一要求，只关注自己内心的想法。稍后回来，我们将探讨大家都能学习的更具说服力的策略。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。13世纪，意大利神秘主义者圣方济各曾做过一个祈祷。他在祈祷中说，理解他人比被他人理解更重要。这在800年前是良言，今天依然适用。这不仅是从精神层面来看，在影响他人的能力方面，它也被证明具有深刻的心理学洞见。
At Stanford University, Rob Willer studies the psychology of persuasion. Rob, we've looked at how we are often ineffective when we try to ram our ideas down other people's throats, but you've run experiments where you measure what effects forceful arguments have in helping us to recruit allies. Can you tell me about this work? Yeah, so some of the work that we've done on this has focused on the tactics used by activists that are agitating for social change on some kind of a cause. And what we found in our experiments is that people tend to have negative reactions to what we describe as extreme protest tactics.
在斯坦福大学，罗伯·威勒研究说服心理学。罗伯，我们已经看到，当我们试图强行将自己的观点灌输给别人时，往往是无效的，但你做过实验，测量过强硬的论点在招募盟友方面有什么影响。你能跟我谈谈这项工作吗？好的，我们在这方面所做的一些工作集中在活动人士为某种事业进行社会变革时所使用的策略上。我们在实验中发现，人们往往会对我们所描述的极端抗议策略产生负面反应。
So this would be like the destruction of property, you know, extreme disruption of, you know, the flow of everyday life for people and certainly the use of violence. So when activists engage in even a relatively small amount of this form of activist behavior, it tends to put people off. So observers who are kind of watching protesters trying to figure out how should they position themselves
这就像破坏财产，你知道，对人们的日常生活造成极端的干扰，当然还有使用暴力。因此，当活动人士哪怕只是进行少量的这种形式的激进行为时，往往会让人反感。所以，那些正在观察抗议者并试图弄清楚他们应该如何定位自己的人
on this issue? Will they be persuaded by the protesters or not? When they see those kinds of tactics, they tend to view the protesters as less moral, they dis-identify with them, and they not only are not influenced by them, they can exhibit a sort of negative influence pattern where they turn away from the positions and policy platforms of protesters. So in one study you posed a scenario about animal rights protesters. Volunteers read an excerpt that said activists had broken into a cosmetics testing lab, drugged a security guard, ransacked the place, and spray-painted messages on the walls of the building.
在这个问题上，他们会被抗议者说服吗？当他们看到这些策略时，他们往往认为抗议者不那么道德，他们会与抗议者产生疏离感，不仅不会受到他们的影响，甚至可能表现出一种负面影响模式，即背离抗议者的立场和政策纲领。在一项研究中，你提出了一个关于动物权利抗议者的情景。志愿者阅读了一段摘录，称活动人士闯入了一家化妆品测试实验室，给保安下了药，洗劫了现场，并在建筑物墙上喷涂了标语。
They also freed hundreds of animals. How did volunteers respond to this story? So volunteers were turned off by activists who engaged in these extremes. I mean, this is in some ways just about the most extreme activist tactics we've ever presented to participants in studies. They were turned off, saw these activists as more extreme, and turned away from animal rights as a cause that they supported. However, if those same activists were portrayed in another condition of the experiment as not engaging in these sort of violent tactics, but instead engaging in peaceful, nonviolent
他们还释放了数百只动物。志愿者对这个故事有何反应？志愿者对参与这些极端行为的活动人士感到反感。我的意思是，在某些方面，这几乎是我们向研究参与者展示过的最极端的抗议策略。他们感到反感，认为这些活动人士更加极端，并转而反对他们所支持的动物权利事业。然而，如果同样的活动人士在实验的另一个条件下被描述为没有参与这些暴力策略，而是参与和平、非暴力的
resistance, the reaction was very different. They were not seen as extreme and it didn't lead to this negative influence effect. So in other words, people were not rejecting the activists because they necessarily disagreed with the cause, but because they disagreed with the methods. That's right. And we've tried really hard in this research to whenever possible, control for the message,
抵抗，反应就大不相同了。他们没有被视为极端，也没有导致这种负面影响效应。换句话说，人们拒绝这些活动人士并不一定是因为他们不同意这项事业，而是因为他们不同意这些方法。没错。在这项研究中，我们非常努力地在可能的情况下控制信息，
control for what policies are being advocated for by activists and only experimentally study and vary how they're making their case, what sorts of tactics they're engaging in, because that's the thing that we were interested in. So in another study, you had some volunteers read about a Black Lives Matter protest. Some volunteers heard activists protesting against racism. Others heard about activists who used a chant in an actual protest. I want to play you a little clip.
控制活动人士所倡导的政策，并仅通过实验研究和改变他们表达观点的方式，以及他们所采取的策略，因为这正是我们感兴趣的地方。在另一项研究中，你让一些志愿者阅读关于“黑人的命也是命”抗议活动的内容。一些志愿者听到活动人士抗议种族主义。另一些志愿者则听到了活动人士在实际抗议中使用口号。我想给你播放一小段录音。
Pigs in the blanket, fry like bacon. Pigs in the blanket, fry like bacon. Pigs in the blanket, fry like bacon. The protesters are saying pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon, a derogatory reference to police as pigs. Now, seeing angry things about the police doesn't seem as extreme as drugging a security guard, but what effect did this language have on potential allies?
猪在毯子里，像培根一样煎。猪在毯子里，像培根一样煎。猪在毯子里，像培根一样煎。抗议者说“猪在毯子里，像培根一样煎”，这是将警察称为“猪”的贬义称呼。现在，说关于警察的愤怒言论似乎不像给保安下药那么极端，但这种语言对潜在的盟友有什么影响呢？
So in this research, we found that that kind of language had a similar effect, just in terms of also creating this negative influence effect. It wasn't as large of an effect, if I recall correctly, but it did tend to turn observers away from the cause of police reform. It seems that there's a dilemma here in some ways, which is that I think protesters feel, just like we often feel in interpersonal arguments, that the more passionately we make our argument, the more likely we are to persuade someone else.
在这项研究中，我们发现那种语言有类似的效果，就产生这种负面影响效应而言。如果我没记错的话，这种影响没有那么大，但它确实倾向于让观察者远离警察改革的事业。这似乎在某种程度上是一个困境，因为我认为抗议者觉得，就像我们在人际争论中经常感觉到的那样，我们表达论点越充满激情，就越有可能说服别人。
I think at the level of groups, we also believe that the more passionately we pursue our cause, the more likely we are not just to convince our opponents, but to attract allies to our cause. And I think Yuri Sutter is suggesting that that might not always be the case. Yeah, that's right. We call it the activist dilemma to really describe these many dilemmas that activists face in trying to take effective action in the world. We found that when we surveyed a small sample
我认为在群体层面，我们也相信我们追求事业的激情越强烈，就越有可能不仅说服我们的对手，还能吸引盟友加入我们的事业。我认为尤里·萨特暗示情况可能并非总是如此。是的，没错。我们称之为“活动人士困境”，用来描述活动人士在试图采取有效行动时所面临的许多困境。我们发现，当我们调查一小部分
of self-identified activists that they tended to think that the more extreme protest tactics would be more persuasive to bystanders, not less persuasive as our research had found. Why did they think that? Well, perhaps because those protest tactics matched their own, you know, viscerally felt motivations better.
自认为是活动人士的人时，他们往往认为更极端的抗议策略对旁观者更有说服力，而不是像我们的研究发现的那样缺乏说服力。他们为什么会这么想？嗯，也许是因为这些抗议策略更好地契合了他们自己内心深处感受到的动机。
And so for them, that was maybe a more relatable set of protest actions. And so you say, oh, yeah, that'll be more persuasive. That that reaction makes sense. That's how you should protest this issue that's totally outrageous. And that's not to say they're wrong. They may be very right about the flaws of the status quo. I tend to agree with many, many activists on these things. But the challenge is that certain tactics
所以对他们来说，这可能是一套更容易产生共鸣的抗议行动。所以你会说，哦，是的，那会更有说服力。那种反应是有道理的。这就是你应该如何抗议这个完全令人愤慨的问题。这并不是说他们错了。他们可能在现状的缺陷方面是非常正确的。我倾向于在这些事情上同意许多许多活动人士的观点。但挑战在于某些策略
do turn off potential supporters in a way that can be on the whole counterproductive for a cause. You say that one way to become more effective at persuasion is to employ something that you call moral reframing. And you've run studies where you test the effectiveness of messages that call moral reframing. And you've run studies where you test the effectiveness of messages that use moral reframing. Can you explain what it is and what the studies have found? Sure, yeah.
确实会让潜在的支持者反感，从整体上讲，这可能对事业适得其反。你说提高说服力的一种方法是采用你所谓的“道德重构”。你做过测试道德重构信息有效性的研究。你做过测试使用道德重构信息有效性的研究。你能解释一下它是什么以及研究发现了什么吗？当然，可以。
So moral reframing involves recasting an argument for a political position that you're advocating for in terms of the moral values of the people that you're talking with. And so this might seem incredibly intuitive, like of course you should frame in terms of the moral values of the people that you're talking with. And so this might seem incredibly intuitive, like of course you should frame your argument in terms of the values of the person
道德重构涉及根据你所交谈对象的道德价值观，重新构建你所倡导的政治立场的论点。这看起来可能非常直观，就像你当然应该根据你所交谈对象的道德价值观来构建你的论点一样。这看起来可能非常直观，就像你当然应该根据你所交谈对象的价值观来构建你的论点一样
you're trying to persuade. After all, if you were trying to sell a car, let's say you would talk about the value of the car for the person you're trying to sell the car to. You talk about its reliability, you talk about its good features, you wouldn't talk about how excited you were to get their money and all the stuff you wanted to spend it on. You could easily transcend your perspective to get into the perspective of the recipient.
你试图说服的人。毕竟，如果你试图卖一辆车，假设你会谈论这辆车对你试图卖给的人的价值。你会谈论它的可靠性，谈论它的优点，你不会谈论你拿到他们的钱有多兴奋以及所有你想花钱买的东西。你可以很容易地超越你的视角，进入接收者的视角。
But with politics and religion, these things that we have deep moral investment in, we really struggle to do this. I'm wondering if you can give me some examples of ways that people on different sides of the political spectrum pick a couple of hot button issues. What are ways in which people can speak to someone from the other side using the moral frameworks of their opponents rather than their own moral frameworks? Sure, yeah, so one of the first issues that we took on with this research was
但在政治和宗教方面，这些我们投入了深厚道德情感的事情，我们确实很难做到这一点。我想知道你是否能给我举一些例子，说明政治光谱不同两端的人如何选择几个热门话题。人们可以用对手的道德框架而不是自己的道德框架与对方交谈，有哪些方式？当然，我们在这项研究中处理的第一个问题是
same-sex marriage. And we were interested in whether the typical arguments for same-sex marriage that are made, that are in terms of values like social justice, fairness, equality, that maybe they're not as persuasive as they could be with conservatives because they don't target deeply held conservative values. Maybe you could make more persuasive arguments that tapped into things like loyalty and patriotism, these more uniquely conservative values. And so we tested this by presenting conservatives with either fairness and equality-based arguments
同性婚姻。我们感兴趣的是，通常为同性婚姻提出的论点，即社会正义、公平、平等之类的价值观，对于保守派来说可能不像预期的那样有说服力，因为它们没有针对根深蒂固的保守派价值观。也许你可以提出更有说服力的论点，利用忠诚和爱国主义等更独特的保守派价值观。因此，我们通过向保守派展示基于公平和平等的论点来测试这一点
in support of same-sex marriage or these very different arguments in terms of patriotism. So this argument said things like same-sex couples are proud and patriotic Americans. They share the same basic hopes and desires as all Americans, like other proud Americans, gay couples, peacefully build lives together, buy homes, and contribute to the American economy and society. And what we found was that conservatives
支持同性婚姻，或者这些关于爱国主义的非常不同的论点。所以这个论点说，同性伴侣是自豪和爱国的美国人。他们分享着所有美国人相同的基本希望和愿望，像其他自豪的美国人一样，同性伴侣和平地共同生活，购买房屋，并为美国经济和社会做出贡献。我们发现，保守派
who heard that patriotism and loyalty-based argument were more supportive of same-sex marriage afterwards. It reduced polarization on same-sex marriage and in favor of the Liberals' position on it. Rob also tested his strategy of moral reframing on the other side of the aisle. He gave Liberals an argument about increased military spending. But this argument wasn't a traditional one about patriotism and protecting our borders. Robinus colleagues presented an argument that focused on more stereotypically liberal values
听到那个基于爱国主义和忠诚的论点后，对同性婚姻更加支持。它减少了在同性婚姻问题上的两极分化，并倾向于自由派的立场。罗伯还测试了他的道德重构策略在政治光谱的另一端。他给了自由派一个关于增加军费开支的论点。但这个论点不是关于爱国主义和保护我们边界的传统论点。罗伯和他的同事提出了一个专注于更典型的自由派价值观的论点
like equality and social justice. And it said things like, through the military, the disadvantage and the poor can achieve equal standing. And being in the military means having a reliable salary and a future apart from the challenges of extreme poverty and inequality. And so this argument really tried to say, you could see the military as a vehicle
比如平等和社会正义。它说，通过军队，弱势群体和穷人可以获得平等的地位。而在军队意味着拥有可靠的薪水和远离极端贫困和不平等挑战的未来。所以这个论点真的试图说，你可以把军队看作是一个工具
for upward mobility for people that struggle to access the kinds of resources and experience that they can gain through the act. That's the kinds of resources and experience that they can gain through the military. It's the kind of argument that might persuade a liberal. And we found that when liberals heard this argument, they supported high levels of military spending more. I'm wondering whether you ever get pushed back on this, Rob. Do people who feel very passionately say,
为那些难以获得他们可以通过军队获得的资源和经验的人提供向上流动的机会。这就是他们可以通过军队获得的资源和经验。这是一种可能说服自由派的论点。我们发现，当自由派听到这个论点时，他们更支持高水平的军费开支。我想知道你是否曾经遇到过对此的抵制，罗伯。那些充满激情的人会说，
you know, Rob Willer is telling me that I need to tone down what it is that I'm saying, that I need to actually look at things from the point of view of my opponents. And these are people who might not only disagree with, these are people who might despise. Right. Yeah. No, we've definitely gotten pushback on this research. I think sometimes people mistake my motivation as one that's critical of your average
“你知道，罗伯·威勒告诉我需要淡化我的言论，我需要真正从对手的角度看问题。”而这些人可能不仅不同意，甚至可能鄙视。没错。是的，我们确实在研究中受到了抵制。我认为有时人们误解了我的动机，认为我是在批评普通的
protester or activist or is interested in doing tone policing. And it's really not the motivation that brings me to the research. You know, instead, I am very interested in what kinds of tactics and strategies for achieving social change are more or less effective. And I'm also, you know, really interested in ways in which it can be really complicated and more complicated than you might think from just reading like our first paper on extreme protest tactics.
抗议者或活动人士，或者有兴趣进行“语气警察”行为。这真的不是促使我进行这项研究的动机。相反，我非常感兴趣的是，什么样的策略和战术对于实现社会变革更有效或更不有效。而且，我也确实对它可能非常复杂的方式感兴趣，比你仅仅阅读我们关于极端抗议策略的第一篇论文所能想到的要复杂得多。
Some years ago, Rob had the chance to put his own research to the test. He was a professor at the University of California Berkeley and had parked his car on campus while he went on a trip to the East Coast. The morning after he flew back to California, Rob went to retrieve his car from the parking lot. There was just one problem. He couldn't find it. And I could not remember if I had even driven it the day before, because I was kind of tired
几年前，罗伯有机会将自己的研究付诸实践。他是加州大学伯克利分校的教授，在去东海岸旅行时把车停在了校园里。回到加州的第二天早上，罗伯去停车场取车。只有一个问题。他找不到车了。我甚至不记得前一天是否开过车，因为我当时有点累，
and running errands. And I just wasn't sure where my car was and whether it had been stolen or whether I had just left it somewhere. And the car was so old and, you know, just run down that it seemed unlikely it was stolen, you know? It seemed more likely I had left it somewhere even though that's a very spacey thing to do.
还在跑腿。我只是不确定我的车在哪里，是被偷了还是我把它停在某个地方了。那辆车太旧了，你知道，破破烂烂的，看起来不太可能被偷，你知道吗？看起来更有可能是我把它停在某个地方了，尽管那是一件非常健忘的事情。
And I remember I went to like the local grocery store and I was like, hey, did you guys tow a car from this parking lot by any chance? And the person was like, you're telling me you don't remember if you parked your car here yesterday? The absent-minded professor here. Yeah, I used that crutch. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, absent-minded. They're like, oh yeah, I had a roommate that was like you. And I was like, could you just tell me if you towed the car, you know? They hadn't towed the car. Rob had no idea where it had gone, and he had little time to think about
我记得我去了当地的杂货店，我说，嘿，你们有没有从这个停车场拖走一辆车？那个人说，你是说你不记得昨天是否把车停在这里了？这里有个健忘的教授。是的，我用了那个借口。是的，是的，健忘。他们说，哦，是的，我有个室友就像你一样。我说，你能告诉我你们是否拖走了那辆车吗？他们没有拖走那辆车。罗伯不知道车去哪了，他也没时间去想
it. He was scheduled to teach a class in Germany for a week and a half. Rob went on his trip and reported the car stolen, planning to take care of it when he got back. But when he returned home, he discovered that the police had been trying to contact him. The stolen car had been found and had been dropped off at an impound lot in Oakland. Rob hitched a ride with a friend and went to the lot. And it's just this kind of mad max dystopian scene.
这件事。他计划去德国教书一个半星期。罗伯去旅行并报告车被偷了，打算回来后再处理。但当他回到家时，他发现警察一直在试图联系他。被盗的车辆已被找到，并被送到了奥克兰的一个扣押场。罗伯搭朋友的车去了那个停车场。那简直就是《疯狂的麦克斯》那种反乌托邦场景。
You know, like all these cars are like falling apart. It's all barbed wire. And it's very razor wire. It's very intense. And I go in, there's behind like two inches of bulletproof glass is this person that's working at the impound lot. And I ask him, you know, about my car.
你知道，所有的车都快散架了。到处都是铁丝网。那是剃刀铁丝网。非常紧张。我走进去，在两英寸厚的防弹玻璃后面，是那个在扣押场工作的人。我问他关于我的车的事。
He's like, yeah, we've got your car. Rob's car was in terrible shape. It was falling apart, missing a catalytic converter, and for some reason, there was an empty bucket in the backseat. Rob had no time to ask questions. He was ready to leave the automotive purgatory. But when he went to fill out his paperwork, the clerk delivered some bad news. Rob owed $600, the fee for holding his decrepit car at the lot for days on end. It just doesn't seem fair, you know, like I was out of the country, I don't know if this helps at all. And he's like, yeah, it's going to be $600. And I was like, you could keep the car, would you
他说，是的，我们有你的车。罗伯的车状况很糟糕。它快散架了，缺少催化转化器，而且不知为何，后座上有一个空桶。罗伯没时间问问题。他准备离开这个汽车炼狱。但当他去填写文书工作时，职员带来了一些坏消息。罗伯欠了600美元，这是将他那辆破车在停车场停放多天的费用。这看起来不公平，你知道，我当时在国外，我不知道这是否有帮助。他说，是的，要600美元。我说，你可以留下这辆车，你会
keep the car? Would that be with that neutralize my debt? Because it's to me, it's not worth $600, especially in this condition. And I remember the guy was like, yeah, we'll keep your car, but you would still owe us $600. Rob's blood was boiling. He felt the way he did all those years ago, an exhausted young restaurant worker angry at his roommate for intruding on his sleep. But this time, instead of throwing a shoe, Rob stopped.
留下这辆车吗？那会抵消我的债务吗？因为对我来说，它不值600美元，特别是在这种情况下。我记得那个人说，是的，我们会留下你的车，但你仍然欠我们600美元。罗伯的血在沸腾。他感觉就像多年前一样，一个疲惫的年轻餐馆员工，因为室友打扰了他的睡眠而生气。但这一次，罗伯没有扔鞋子，而是停了下来。
He thought for a moment. He considered what it might be like on the other side of that bulletproof glass. And so I asked him, I was like, what percentage of people like freak out right now in this conversation? And he said like 70% of people. And I was like, cool, all right. You know, the reason I was interested in that was because at this time I was teaching introduction to social psychology and I was giving this essay assignment to, you know, hundreds of
他想了一会儿。他考虑了防弹玻璃另一边的人会是什么感觉。所以我问他，我说，现在在这个对话中，有多少比例的人会抓狂？他说大约70%的人。我说，酷，好吧。你知道，我之所以对那个感兴趣，是因为当时我正在教社会心理学导论，我每年给成百上千的
students every year. But it also made me very interested in, you know, what, what rate do people make the right choice here, you know? And, and when he said 70%, I was like, okay, I'm gonna do my best to not be in that group, you know? And I turned to my friend and we start trying to strategize, what are we gonna do? You know, like is my car drivable? If it's not drivable, could we sell it from the parking lot of the impound lot? You know, like what what are going to do to solve this dilemma? And the guy behind the glass starts looking up like the blue book value for the car and quoting us, you know, what we could expect and giving advice on toers.
学生布置这篇论文作业。但这也让我非常感兴趣，你知道，人们在什么比例下会做出正确的选择？当他说70%时，我说，好吧，我会尽我所能不成为那一组的人。我转向我的朋友，我们开始尝试制定策略，我们要怎么做？你知道，我的车还能开吗？如果不能开，我们能在扣押场的停车场把它卖掉吗？我们要怎么解决这个困境？玻璃后面的人开始查找汽车的蓝皮书价值，并报价，你知道，我们可以期待什么，并就拖车服务提供建议。
And it's like really helping us. And I was like, oh, wow, you know, like some of this is because we connected when I didn't do the easy thing that I was so emotionally tempted to do, of unfairly going off on this guy, and down-regulated that and was a decent person instead, and he reciprocated it and was really decent back. And it was me learning this lesson even a little bit more. And what happened to the car eventually?
他真的在帮助我们。我说，哦，哇，你知道，这其中有一些原因是因为当我们没有做我情绪上非常想做的简单事情时，我们建立了联系，即不公平地对这个人发火，我降低了那种情绪，表现得像个正派的人，他也做出了回应，表现得非常正派。这是我学到的又一课。那辆车最后怎么样了？
Yeah, I donated it to charity, but yeah, it was so easy to break into. It was surprising that it had taken that long to be actually stolen. And also they had left my San Francisco Giants foam finger in the car. I guess they were A's fans. raised fans. When Rob Willer is not negotiating with people about impounded cars, he's a sociologist at Stanford University. Rob, thanks so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Absolutely. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes
是的，我把它捐给了慈善机构，但它确实太容易被闯入了。令人惊讶的是，它花了那么长时间才真正被偷。而且他们还把我的旧金山巨人队泡沫手指留在了车里。我猜他们是运动家队的球迷。当罗伯·威勒不与人商谈扣押车辆时，他是斯坦福大学的社会学家。罗伯，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。当然。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括
Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week, in our Ask Two-Pointer series, when we are fighting with someone, we're often tempted to tell them to take a walk. New research suggests we should take that walk with them. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周，在我们的“询问双指针”系列中，当我们与某人争吵时，我们经常想告诉他们走开。新的研究建议我们应该和他们一起走。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。